- Yo what up guys, this
is a mashup that the
team is putting together
of our Empathy Wine
kind of telethon infomercial QVC session,
some of the best notes, the hightlights,
and most of all if you
watch this, please go
to Empathywines.com and order now.
(airplane sounds)
You guys want perspective.
(upbeat music)
You want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
Anything I can answer for you?
- [Male Caller] (mumbles)
I'm not sure exactly what I want
to do, I'm just--
- How old are you?
- I'm 27.
- Perfect bro, it's early.
27's a tricky year, a lot
of people get confused
because they see 30, it's not far away,
they don't think they're a kid anymore,
I need to rewrite society
on this, you're a kid
until you're 45, you're early bro.
- Yeah so (mumbling)
we're just trying to figure
out what the best way,
how to go about it.
- I would pick one, the
bell is ringing now,
maybe people are hearing me.
So, you pick one and
you do it, and you do it
for six months to a year, and if you like
where it's going you keep doing it,
and if not take those experiences and
you pick the next one.
Literally write down
with your homies the nine
ideas, put it in a hat, pull one,
and fucking start at the next day.
This is a world of action, not
fucking contemplation.
- Okay that's true, I do take a long time
- Of course dude, because
you're worried about
failing, right?
People disguise perfection
and contemplation
on their fear of failing, just fucking
go bro.
- Just whatever ideas (mumbling)
- These are nine, listen
bro, you have 47,000
ideas, 800 billion things
you could be doing,
but you've picked nine,
all of them are good.
Angela,
(classical music plays)
- [female caller] Hello
- Angelique?
- Oh my Gosh
- I wanna call you and thank you
- Yeah I've been watching
you until I answered
- Thank you so, so much
for ordering the wine,
it means a lot to me.
- Thank you so, so much for calling.
- Yeah, what's going on?
Anything I can answer for you?
- Yeah, so it would be
awesome, well I just
started to switch up my Instagram,
basically I'm an esthetician, I do eyelash
extensions, and I'm like crazy booked
- Well first of all,
there's so many people right
now that are crazy booked, cutting hair,
making a painting, doing nails, do eye
extensions, doing massages, doing
meditation services, immediately,
and this is how your gonna make all your
money back on the wine you just bought,
you have to raise your price tomorrow.
- Okay
- If you are over booked,
and you have demand,
you have to raise,
how much do you cost?
- Well there's like fills, (mumbling)
If they don't have anything on, its $165.
If they're coming for a fill, its $50,
they start at $50.
And it goes up ten dollars
each week they wait.
- You have to, have to, raise your prices,
your base price, you have to.
- Okay.
- I mean, you're over booked right?
- Right, that's why everyone says to do,
and I know, but all
these girls are doing it
illegally just to make money,
and doing it for cheap
out of their basement.
- Listen to me, and I play basketball,
and LeBron gets paid a billion to play it,
like don't worry about price, worry about
supply and demand.
If you're in demand, guess what, people
give speeches on business for free.
I'm 150,000.
- Okay
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, completely.
- I don't give a shit if you're doing it
illegally in the allies behind your house.
- (laughing) Okay
- Do not factor other
people's prices into your
strategy and the supply and demand of you.
- Okay.
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, of course.
- I'm telling your right
now, I'm gonna check
your shit, I'm gonna
have somebody call you.
Its gonna be in a women's
voice, because he's got
a girly voice. He's gonna
be like hey and he's
gonna try to set up an
appointment, and if you
tell me your prices that you just quoted,
we're finished, you and I.
- Oh shit, okay.
- And you're not gonna know when its gonna
happen, its probably not
gonna happen tomorrow,
but it can happen at any
time, and I'm telling
you right now, it will
be the greatest decision
you make.
And the reason I'm excited
about this advice is
I know I have thousands
of people watching on
Facebook and Instagram,
and for a lot of people,
they're scared to raise
their price, it's the
most common one woman, one man show issue
out there.
But if you're fucking
booked, if your phone's
ringing, if people are
sliding into the DM and
and trying to do business,
if you're getting asked,
and you don't have time
to do it, you have to raise your price.
- Okay.
- You're raising your
price tomorrow, I'm telling
you right now, tomorrow
you're raising your
prices. The next person that asks,
not $165, $199.
- Okay.
- And when they say no,
I don't want to hear fuck
Gary, he gave me the
wrong advice, cause that's
only a focus group of one.
- Right.
- Until you get 39 no's
in a row, you haven't hit
the wrong price.
- Okay.
- Are you scared to raise your price?
Don't lie.
- No, I'm not scared to raise my price,
I know I should be doing
it for a while, but
like I said it's hard
when everyone else's is
lower, you know.
- What did we say?
- We don't care.
- We don't fucking care
about anybody else.
- Right.
- We spit on everybody else.
- True.
- We don't even acknowledge
their existence,
I don't even know any other agency and any
other wine, any other sneaker,
I don't even know of.
- (laughing)
- Everybody asked me
last night, Gary what do
you think of the Patriots?
I'm like I don't give a
fuck! It has nothing to
do with me.
- Yeah, they're cheaters.
- Yes, I like you already.
So, do you understand
though? Listen, tonight
is the phone call.
This is why I always say
doing the right thing
is the right thing.
You, unlike the thousands
of people that are
watching that have
gotten tons of money out
of my free advice, you
have decided to actually
support me in return,
which I thank you for.
That is doing the right
thing. I, then keep
you on the phone, and
I'm not just mailing this
call in.
I'm making sure that this call changes
your career.
- [male caller] I've been working with my
dad's business, and
Facebook attributions in
terms of things are
doing, they can give you
a sign, but, obviously
(mumbles) how things
have been going, and its been helping,
but is there anything
in terms specifically
frequency
- I got one for you. How many pieces of
content are you running ads against?
- Not enough.
- The end.
The biggest secret in 2019 to Facebook, to
make it work better for people that have
started to do it a little
bit is more content.
Volume of content.
You're targeting in
the area of Chandler or
Arizona, or Pacific
Southwest, it could be right,
but if the content is
garbage, then you're gonna
loose.
Or if you've run the content to people and
they've seen the same ad over and over,
literally one adjective can change
the outcome.
- Right.
More specific and more content.
- Yes, making the content more narrow and
the targeting more out narrow, paying more
CPM's, but getting the business result
you're looking for.
- Right. Right on.
- Got it?
- I do.
- The answer is the
content, not the media.
That's where people are getting fucked up.
- Right, and what percentage
does the advertiser
should spend on Facebook
and Instagram (mumbles)
- I mean it depends on
a business, you need to
run it.
I don't care if somebody
runs 80 percent of
their money on direct mail.
If they've spent so much money and tried
so many things, that
it's proven that that's
better. So there's no right answer.
But my big thing is, if you haven't really
run the volume of
content game on Facebook,
you've gotta really, really, ask yourself,
you know?
- Right, yeah. And what
works is what works,
and you go (mumbles)
- I have no emotion, I have no emotion.
I just want results.
- Right.
- I don't give a shit about Facebook and
Instagram. I give a shit about results.
I just know that Facebook
and Instagram ads
are grossly under priced for the attention
they give you back. You don't know what to
fill that attention with.
A lot of people could be live streaming
right now.
If john and Nate were
live streaming right now
for wines, we would have
sold one fucking bell.
Anything I can answer for you right now?
- What's your take on humor and
business intersecting?
- Give me a little more color on that.
I think humor is a
foundational characteristic
that always plays in society, but what
do you mean?
- I totally understand
when you're starting
out young in business,
going super niche is
a smart approach.
- Okay.
- But when you try to
be more of a generalist
when you're starting out and your touching
a lot of different
industries, there's certain
fundamental traits to lean into.
- Okay.
- In my mind, humor is an amazing one to
take advantage of.
So I guess, where does
that fall, not taking
seriously as you're developing yourself?
- Dude, life is always
about the end result,
people said to me I would not be taken
seriously because I cursed.
If you can bring it, everything is
taken seriously.
- Yeah, absolutely
- That's the right take.
That's the absolute
right take. The end.
- Yeah, that's cool, I appreciate it.
- Thank you bro, keep being funny.
- Alright.
- See you later.
- (laughing) I gotta
work on the funny part.
- (laughing) got it. Talk to ya.
Hey how are you?
- [female voice] I am fantastic.
- Thank you so much for supporting
empathywines.com unlike many people here.
- I can't wait to get my first taste,
I'm stoked.
- Thank you so much, is there anything
I can answer for you?
- No, just wanted to tell you I'm a
Tom Ferry coach and client, which I know
you know Tom Ferry.
- I do.
How's real estate?
- Real estate is great, its fantastic.
I opened up my own independent office and
I'm a licensed broker
in Missouri and Kansas.
But really I have to
confess, I started watching
the Good Wife around the holidays time on
Netflix, and now I've got this really bad
addition.
- Well here's the good news, you're gonna
give me an opportunity to create clarity.
You can watch Netflix 24/7 365 if
you're happy.
To me, the people that
I go after on Netflix
or video games,
by the way, I watched
the Jets for three hours
16 Sundays a year.
My big thing is if you're complaining or
your saying that you're gonna build a
billion dollar empire, then you've gotta
put in hard work. If
you're unhappy, here's
what scares me Lydia, most people that
are unhappy use Netflix or Fortnite or
gambling or alcohol or reading books to
escape their truth.
- Yes.
- So for me, it's why not make your life
actually happy and do things you like and
live within the means of
the things that you like
where you can earn
income, so that you don't
need to use those things
to escape your truth.
- Indeed.
- So, to me, I love people that watch,
binge watch Netflix and are equally happy.
That means you're finding the balance of
escapism and fulfillment.
- [female voice] Something that I struggle
with a lot is self doubt.
- From the parents.
- Not just that, but I put it on myself,
a lot of it.
- No you don't, that is
the number one mistake
that everybody thinks.
Everybody thinks that
they put their own self
doubt on themselves, it's actually not how
it works.
Outside forces got into
your head, and then
made you self doubt.
You think it's your voice.
Nobody's voice hates
them in the beginning.
It's a voice that's been implanted in you,
either in the beginning
from your neighborhood
outside force, and often parents, and so,
where people get really fucked up,
is they think like when I talk about the
Jones', they're like fuck.
I don't care about other people, it's that
I shit on myself, and I'm trying to get
people to understand,
you're not shitting on
yourself, you've taken on the voice of
somebody on the outside.
- Right.
- You weren't born with like I hate me.
You've taken on the voice of somebody
from the outside.
It's very important that
you understand this.
I'll tell you why.
It gets a lot easier if
you actually believe it
and understand it.
Because then you can understand it, verses
laying there and being like why do I
hate myself? You know what I mean?
- Right.
- Somebody planted their
insecurities on you.
It's why a lot of people
get value out of me
because through my practical optimism,
not my delusional you're
an eighth place trophy,
but from my practical optimism,
if people keep putting
that voice in your ears,
the reason listen to so much of my content
is I'm optimistic, but
I'm not gonna sugar coat
it and be like if you
just wish it it happens.
And in that balance,
overtime, if that's what
goes into your ears, then all of a sudden,
you start believing it.
I genuinely believe it. I believe that the
two of us should never doubt ourselves.
Why? I don't understand.
I think I suck
at most things, but I
need to go find that out
for myself, not do it
because I'm worried about
somebody judging me on my failure.
- Yeah, I think part of it, I've taken on.
A lot of people will say like, you take
on the worst from your parents, I don't
completely agree with that.
You take on some of the best, and you have
to break the chain of what was the worst.
- You're a 100 percent in charge, too.
One of the things, especially when you're
younger.
The fact that you just
said that, I understand
that.
A lot of conversation
in my own family is how
us three kids took on
different traits from
our parents.
But the reality is, that you're just
fundamentally in control.
There's a ton of things
that I'm similar to
my parents on, and there's things that I
decided to audit, and
overtime, chip away at,
by just talking about it, you know.
If you talk to yourself
about it, everything
is solvable.
I just really believe that. It just is.
It just depends on what you're willing to
listen to. If you listen to you Aunt,
who says you've taken
on the worst things of
your parents, you're gonna loose.
- Right.
- I don't know what else to say.
This is just the way
it is. I'm just really
happy that we're interacting this much,
because honestly, its funny, I just want
people to listen to me
as much as possible,
until they don't need to listen to me,
and then I don't want them to listen to me
at all.
- The difference with
me, its crazy that we've
been (mumbling)
Do I buy a ticket to go down to Atlanta?
I wanted it so bad and I didn't get it.
I promise I'm gonna see
Gary again, I'm gonna
talk to him because I know why I belong,
and I know when somebody inspires me as
much as you do, I belong
in that same circle.
- Well look.
I appreciate that. Lets talk about it.
So there's obviously this circle, right?
Internships, team Gary, and then there's
companies that I'm involved.
Bit I gotta tell you, the thing that I'm
most proud of, is that I'm making myself
outrageously accessible, right?
Look what I'm doing right now.
Nobody's trying harder
to create access for
their community.
I'm one human and there's only so much I
can do, but I promise you, this is just
the beginning.
I'm gonna do this for the next fucking
50 years.
More importantly, listen
to me, this is binary.
If you actually use this time that we've
interacted, this time, to understand that
any level of self doubt or insecurity that
you have in your head
is literally been put
inside of it, and its
not you doing it to you,
it will change your fucking young life.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching
my video on YouTube, I wanted to jump
in here a the end because I'm working
on a ridiculously
important project for me,
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all, or know anybody
that drinks wine at all, please go to
empathywines.com now, and sign up
for subscription.
Whether it's a three pack, whether it's a
six pack, or whether it's a whole case of
each for the year.
If you drink 36 bottles of wine a year or
give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for club Empathy.
This project means the world to me and
could really use your support.